[Musik]
in Kiel soll auf dem Gelände der
Uniklinik ein neuer Gebäudekomplex für
den Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Bereich entstehen
ein Neubau gibt es schon aber der wird
jetzt gerade wieder abgerissen wegen
einer Umplanung passt er nicht mehr ins
Konzept und muss als Rohbau gerade
fertiggestellt schon wieder weg
absolute Frechheit absolute Frechheit
dass das überhaupt passieren kann normal
müsste es doch doppelt durchgeplant
werden dann meiner Meinung nach sowas
bauen die da was neues schönes hin für
den Krankenhaus und jetzt wieder
abzureißen das ist ich finde das
Schwachsinn man fragt sich dann immer ob
sowas nicht in vorhinein irgendwie mal
geplant werden kann ob da nicht
irgendwie gewisse Leute für
verantwortlich sind die sowas vielleicht
hätten vorher schon mal vorhersehen
können und ja Unverständnis in Kiel soll
eigentlich das denkmalgeschützte
hno-gebäude saniert werden doch im
vergangenen Jahr stellen die Planer fest
dass das alte Gebäude zu marode ist es
wird abgerissen das Problem und das
historische Gebäude hatte man voreilig
diesen Erweiterungsbau angesetzt aber
jetzt ist der Altbau weg und damit passt
auch der Neubau nicht mehr ins Konzept
denn das gerade errichtete Gebäude ist
plötzlich nicht mehr zeitgemäß die
Deckenhöhe waren dem historischen
Gebäude orientiert heute baut man höher
und der Neubau wird deshalb tatsächlich
wieder abgerissen das ganze soll mehr
Kosten in Höhe von 1,9 Millionen Euro
verursachen ja das ist wieder typischer
planungswahnsinn in Deutschland das ist
die überbauende Bürokratie da kann man
wirklich nur den Kopf schütteln und
wirklich nicht mehr an sich halten also
ich denke bei solchen Ausgaben sollte
man doch genauer hingucken oder aber
warum wurde schon gebaut bevor die
Sanierung des Altbaus sicher war und
warum kann der Neubau nicht doch
integriert werden diese Fragen stellen
wir der Pressestelle der Uniklinik aber
dort wo man sich weder vor der Kamera
noch schriftlich äußern kein Problem
ihre Meinung zu sagen haben hingegen die
Menschen in Kiel
und daher ist das für mich
unerklärlich
dass soweit etwas in der heutigen Zeit
noch passieren kann so ich bei meiner
Arbeit bei mir wird vorausgesetzt dass
ich vorausdenke und nützlich bin so und
wenn die Leute das hier nicht hinkriegen
finde ich echt ein bisschen traurig aber
es ist ein bisschen absurd und
lächerlich so demnächst ist der Schutt
abgeräumt und das Baufeld frei dann wird
hier eine ganz neue Klinik errichtet das
klappt dann hoffentlich problemlos und
die große Abriss Schere kommt nicht
wieder zum Einsatz